wanna die sometimes
[Music]
me
nobody loves me
[Music]
will you let me go
let him go
[Music]
me
so you think you can stop
[Music]
love me and leave me baby
anyone can't see me
nothing really matters
to me
[Music]
please
hello
[Music]
somehow i think you got to stop down
you really don't remember
all the voices in your head
[Music]
you
hurry up but you really don't remember
[Music]
all the voices in your head
oh
when you're married for
don't believe it's coming back soon
and you really don't remember
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
that you've been living under
sorry
[Music]
blue jean baby
i
[Music]
you must have seen her
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
jesus freaked
out in the street
and then tickets are forgone
[Music]
is not that bad
looking on she sings the song
[Music]
the word she knows
i feel sorry lying here
with no one near only you
and you can hear me
when i stand softly
[Music]
slowly
[Applause]
dance
[Music]
[Applause]
she's
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Applause]
[Music]
you must
now she's in me
always with me
a tiny dancer in my hand
[Music]
when i say softly
is
[Music]
on the
today
[Music]
some folks about
[Applause]
[Music]
it ain't me
my
[Music]
hear me
there is a house
in your house
[Music]
in god
[Applause]
[Music]
potatoes
i
[Music]
daddy
is
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
oh mother tell your children
not to do whatever
[Music]
misery in the house
[Applause]
[Music]
tape
[Applause]
[Music]
because
[Applause]
[Music]
know
me
[Music]
do
do you mean
she said i am the one
she told me her name is
[Music]
mother always
is
[Music]
she says
do
[Music]
just remember to always
she told my baby
the people always told me be careful
what to do
oh
[Music]
is
so
[Music]
she
uh
[Music]
my
me
[Music]
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
a regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
making love to his tonic and gin
[Music]
he says son can you play me a memory
i'm not really sure how it goes
but it's sad and it's sweet and i knew
it complete
when i was
[Music]
sing us a song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me my drinks for free
and he's quick with a joke or to light
up your smoke
but there's some place that he'd rather
be
it says bill i believe this is killing
me
as a smile ran away from his face
well i'm sure that i could be a movie
star
if i could get out of this place
[Music]
novelist who never had time
for a while and he's talking with david
who's still in the navy and probably
will be
[Music]
and the waitress is practicing politics
as the businessmen
slowly get stoned yes they're sharing a
drink they call loveliness
but it's better than drinking alone
[Music]
all right
it's a pretty good crowd for a saturday
and the manager gives me a smile
cause he knows that it's me they've been
coming to see
[Music]
and the microphone smells like a
and they sit beer the bar and put bread
in my jar
and say man what are you doing here
[Music]
tonight well we're all in the mood for
our melody
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
ground control to major tom
ground control to major tongue
take your protein pills and put your
helmet on take
ground control to major terms
seven six commencing
countdown engines on
two check ignition and make god's love
[Music]
and the papers
[Applause]
[Music]
this is made to come to ground control
i'm stepping through the door
and i'm floating in the most peculiar
way
[Applause]
[Music]
am i sitting
i can do
[Music]
um
i'm feeling very scared
[Music]
tell my wife i love her
there's something wrong can you hear me
can you hear me
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
oh
when i gonna come down
when
[Music]
forever i didn't sign up for you
i'm not a present for your friends to
open those boys
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think you'll do then
[Music]
like
my toes
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
beyonce
[Music]
oh lord
can you feel it coming in
[Music]
and i've seen your face
before my friend but i
don't know who i am
[Music]
it's
oh
[Music]
the last time we
i know the reason why
heart doesn't show
[Music]
hold on
oh
[Music]
me
in the morning
hey
[Applause]
i've
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
he's a macho man he likes to be the
[Applause]
leader
[Music]
i've got to
all right
[Music]
oh
hey
[Music]
so much
so
[Music]
now i'm
so many times it happens too fast
don't lose your grip on the dreams of
the past
you must fight just to keep them alive
[Music]
is
rising up straight to the top
[Music]
now i'm not gonna stop
is
[Music]
the tigers
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
god
let's have a good time
[Music]
[Applause]
well i want to thank you i know this is
supposed to be you know
[Music]
the fake news i said that this is
supposed to be a round table but it
looks like a rally but it is a rally
no it's it's it is a round table and
we're here to really listen
we're here to uh discuss the latinos
and the hispanic americans
and uh and i want to say you have a
great governor he's been fantastic
thank you i love you too
uh and we're really uh we're really
doing well the
the country is doing numbers that uh
like we've never
you will you will see next year is going
to be you know you had your greatest
year ever
doug last year the best year you ever
had then we had to close it up
we had to stop and we saved millions of
lives by doing it we saved
millions of lives and then we restarted
and now we've set all kinds of records
and we're setting records and i think
next year you're going to have a
fantastic year it's going to be great
we're cutting taxes even further and
we're going to have big growth a lot of
good things are happening but i'm
thrilled to be back in arizona with
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
by the way i just looked i see artie
over here you've done a great job
how's albert is he good huh good guy
he's a good guy good job barney so it's
really great to be back
i love i mean this is
this is good you know uh this is what
the polls are all saying too you know as
a republican
republicans don't do as well as perhaps
they should and probably some shouldn't
do very well but
the polls came out and we're leading uh
sleepy joe by a lot
and so it's uh it's a great honor to be
here but we're here to discuss my
administration's
unwavering devotion to hispanic american
communities
hispanic americans embody the american
dream and they are great business people
like this guy right here
they're great business people great
great business people
i know that because i've had to compete
with them to compete with i want to say
that
hispanic americans strengthen our nation
beyond description
you protect our nation as brave members
of the military and as members of law
enforcement great great members of law
enforcement
you uplift the communities and promote
our shared values of faith and family
community hard work and patriotism
it's really an amazing you're an amazing
group of people and i love you and we're
taking care of you and i'm never letting
you down
he'll never let you down
so we're glad to be joined by your
fantastic
governor doug ducey he's done a
fantastic job
he really has it's uh it's been it's
been
incredible so and thank you doug thank
you very much mr president
also thanks to arizona republican party
chairman kelly ward
great job kelly how are we doing kelly
by the way
[Applause]
arizona state representative tj shope
thank you very much thanks d.j
arizona corporation commissioner leah
marquez
peterson
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you
sergeant jimmy chavez of the national
troopers coalition
sergeant thank you and we got
we have the law enforcement from all
over the country we just got florida
all the sheriffs all the law enforcement
ohio texas
everywhere new york we got new york's
finest they said they've never endorsed
before but they're endorsing this year
that took a little courage too
because they're in very unfriendly
territory politically
but new york did and we just got chicago
can you believe that with that
with that wonderful wonderful mayor
we also have a man that i have a lot of
respect i like baseball i've always
liked baseball and he's done a fantastic
job artie mourinho
the owner of the los angeles angels been
a fantastic boss
how is albert pujols doing good because
i think he's great huh
good great and you have uh mike trout so
is he as good as they say
they say he's the best player he said
he's he's better he's better right
but they say he's the best player in
baseball that's great
that's very good thanks artie
congratulations on your success
great job also with us are two wonderful
arizona republican nominees for congress
tiffany shed and brandon martin
good luck
thank you brandon and you have my
complete endorsement you know that
complete and total as i say complete and
total
okay and we'll be out working with you
we'll be helping you a lot i hear you
doing both of you doing really well very
important and doug is
doug is working hard on that thank you
very much
joe biden spent 47 years selling out the
hispanic american community
sending you jobs to china raising your
taxes surging regulations
i don't know it doesn't sound too good
to me
it's coming up once every three four
days i've been in every state i've been
in so many states
last few days yeah well you need a lot
of
you need a lot of energy to do this job
properly you can't be sitting in your
basement for four days and come on
now and then he comes out and i like
delaware i think delaware is a good
place but you got to leave it on
occasion you know i mean it comes out
and remember he didn't you know they say
uh that his home state
was pennsylvania no no no he left
pennsylvania
when he was young it's not his fault his
father left okay and his mother
they left but they left pennsylvania
when he was very young and we just had a
great ruling doug and i were talking
just
literally minutes ago a federal judge
a very prominent a very respected
federal judge came out and ruled that
they can't
shut the state down any longer it's too
much
he said it was unconstitutional
we hope that's going to happen in north
carolina
we hope we hope that's going to happen
in north carolina we hope it's going to
happen in michigan too because it's just
just totally shut down well you know
what's going to happen on november 4th
they'll open up everything they're just
doing it
on november 4th they'll announce
everything's open now you know we were
only kidding the fact
is that november 4th you're going to see
it's going to all open up
it's going to all open up its politics
so if you know
and as hispanic americans you know
better than anybody we implemented
historic tax cuts and regulation cuts
the biggest in the history of our
country and we've built opportunity
zones that have really benefited your
state and a lot of other states
and it's been great for everybody really
african-americans and
if you look at the african-american it's
what they have what they've done and how
that's benefited them was
i was helped by tim scott of south
carolina
and he's a fantastic senator and he came
in the idea of the
opportunity zone but for african
americans hispanic americans asian
americans and really everybody it's been
a tremendous success
before the china virus came in we
achieved the lowest hispanic american
unemployment rate
ever recorded ever not even close
over 600 000 hispanic americans were
lifted out of poverty
in that short period of time that's a
record with all records hispanic
american ownership
homeownership reached an all-time high
and that includes artie's home
okay that includes the whole okay that
must be a nice home i want to see that
but it's the highest home ownership ever
in the history of our country for
hispanic american we built the greatest
economy in history
and now we're doing it again so it's
called make america great again
and i say make america great again and
again
again and again
and we added as you probably heard we
added 3.3 million jobs for hispanic
americans in the last four months that's
a record
so we're coming back very very strong i
call it the super v
in july i launched the white house
hispanic prosperity initiative to
improve access
to education and economic development
and opportunity
for all hispanic americans it's been a
very big success we have great people on
the board
and we have that uh biden would as you
know terminate this recovery because if
a doctor said let's shut it down we have
all these records we have retail sales
records everything
he said he'd shut it down can't shut it
down peaceful protesters have you seen
his peaceful protesters
these are not they'll rip down your
community many of these are hispanic
american small businesses stores shops
and they rip them down and they call it
peaceful protesting you see some of
these uh
reporters on television they're saying
yes this has been a peaceful protest
and over his shoulder you know it's a
pretty famous clip the entire city is
burning down
and these are all democrat mayors super
liberal
usually but democrat mayors and
governors republicans are doing very
well republican cities and states are
doing incredibly well
we're at records we have been at records
we will be at records and
we don't have anything like this
nobody's ever seen anything like this
and we've sent the national
guard into minneapolis and we ended it
after
a week and a half they should have
called it sooner we would solve the
problem
in portland in i say less than a half an
hour
it would be so but they don't want to
call us
they don't want to call us in and every
place we've gone we solve it immediately
we we just
seattle as an example they took over a
piece of the city
and we said what are you doing and we
complained complained we said it's okay
we have to go in because we're supposed
to wait
we're going in we're going in tomorrow
and we inform them we're going in as
soon as we did that
they had people go in and these wise
guys gave up the so-called protesters
they gave up
they're anarchists they're not
protesters they're agitators
so you see what happens with the
anti-police rhetoric from that whole
group of
democrats and their supporters they're
endangering our law enforcement we love
our law enforcement many of them
many of the law enforcement many many of
the law enforcement are hispanic
americans as you know
biden is not a strong person never was a
strong person in prime time he wasn't
any good let's face it and this is not
prime time for him this is not prime
time
but he'll surrender your entire country
to the radical left
and that's all they're doing is using
them he has no clue so
we will take this to a whole different
level what we're doing is taking it to a
whole different level
we don't want to have a socialist
country we don't want to have some of
you came
some of you came from parts of the world
where it's socialist or worse
you know it's called the c word right
the c word
because i think in many cases these
people are talking even beyond socialism
and we're not going to let that happen
we're not going to let the rule of law
really be uh just be ruled by the mob
we're going to do it we're going to do
it properly we're going to do it the way
we're doing it
again remember the top ten are all
democrat and then you go into the top 25
and you take a look at that it's the
same thing it's all a democrat problem
whether it's new york where crime is
through the roof it's gone up in some
cases
150 to 300 percent
not even recognizable or chicago you
take a look at chicago what's happening
they had numbers that were just
absolutely horrible and uh were you
hearing i don't even want to mention it
but so many people
shot so many people killed it's nobody's
ever heard of this
this is a democrat runs the city these
are democrats
and they have no clue they have no cash
bail they have
they they get rid of bail they get rid
of
all of the things that you need the the
police are afraid to do anything they
don't want to lose their pensions they
don't want to lose their life they don't
want to lose their family and their job
and everything else that comes with it
and we have to give our great law
enforcement people we have to give them
the respect that they deserve and if we
don't do that they can never do their
job properly
thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much and just in
closing up and i just say a few words
more because it's so important to me and
and
your community is so important to me but
many hispanic americans came here to
pursue the american dream
right you came we all want the america i
want the american dream we all want the
american dream this
is if you you look at what they're
asking for it's like
the american nightmare or whatever you
want to call it
but we want the american dream having
left countries that did not have
safe streets many of you or your family
your mothers your fathers they left
countries that were very very bad
very bad a lot of problems and if we let
this go on you'd have that and
you know i often say we're not going to
be another venezuela we love the people
of venezuela we have
tremendous support in miami from
venezuelans and cubans
we're not going to let that happen to
our country nobody wants it and you know
who wants at least is hispanic americans
they want to see it
less than anybody because they know
about it more than anybody
and so we're not going to let that
happen biden wants to take away your
police he
wants to i wouldn't say defund in his
case but i will tell you some of his
compatriots want to defund your police
let's face it they wanted to fund your
police
they want to take it away they i don't
know who's going to do the job when they
call up at night you saw the commercial
where you call up and they say murder
i'm sorry we won't be here for 24 hours
and then they say i'm sorry
rape we won't be here for about a week
we'll call you back in a week
and this is what you'll end up with we
can't do it we have to treasure our law
enforcement that we have to let them
do what they're good at
another thing i think that's so
important is that we're defending
religious liberty and joe biden will
totally eliminate religious liberty he's
going to take away your second amendment
because he's not going to be what i have
put up with in the last
four years to defend your second
amendment but you have to have your
second amendment and they're going to at
least obliterate it
they're going to at least obliterate it
they're going to abolish school choice
they're going to abolish charter schools
and we're going to put charter schools
all over wherever we can we have so many
people
doing so well and school
and we've been working very hard on
school choice and we'll get it
very much achieved like we have nobody's
done as much as we've done in three and
a half years nobody no administration
in their first three and a half years
i say and i say this that i've achieved
more for hispanic americans in 47 months
than joe biden has achieved in 47 years
they don't call him sleepy jill for
nothing okay
but a vote for republicans this november
is a vote for the american dream and
that's all i have to say i just want to
thank you very much
i want to thank you very much
and and i look forward to hearing from
some of the folks at the table and some
of these
people that i know i have great respect
for all of you i've heard of in one way
or another and
i want to thank you all for being here
really it's uh it's a great honor and
already it's an honor meeting you
and maybe we'll start with our governor
our great governor and doug please a few
words
let me be up thank you
[Music]
let me uh let me be the first to welcome
president donald trump
back to the great state of arizona
and and there couldn't be a a better way
there couldn't be a better way
to kick off hispanic heritage month so
we're thrilled to have you here mr
president
thank you my honor
i want to say thank you for your support
of arizona families
throughout the crisis that we've been
through whether it was
personal protective equipment surge
ventilators for our navajo nation
testing that we needed in places like
south phoenix and maryvale
whenever we needed it your
administration and you
personally delivered so we're grateful
for that
you know doug is very aggressive he
called me up he called me up once he
said
we really need ventilators badly that's
hard you know because it's like they're
big
expensive very complex very tech i mean
from a tech standpoint a high-tech
standpoint they have to be perfect
they're very hard and people don't have
them countries don't have them
and now we've become the king we're
making them like you wouldn't believe
but i said how many do you need
could you send us a thousand i said a
thousand that's a lot
but we got them to you do we get them
you got them too awesome and uh
yeah thank you
and and and before this pandemic and
after this pandemic our
economy has been booming in the state of
arizona this has been the fastest
growing state in the nation
your jobs act and tax cut has done much
to spur our economy
the negotiation of the usmca
has allowed arizona to maximize its
relationship
with its number one trading partner
mexico
and we have now surpassed china with
canada as our number two trading partner
in arizona
thank you very much thank you very much
and the relationship with mexico has
been really great until you have a very
good president and we've gotten along
very well and uh they've actually
been very good we've had a real
relationship you know nafta was a
disaster for our country
and now we have the usmca which is
mexico canada
and it's been a great and we're not
going to lose our businesses now to
mexico and canada they're going to stay
right here so
they have a very big economic penalty if
they want to play the games of leaving i
mean we lost
55 000 firms went down to different i
mean different places but a lot of them
went to mexico a lot of them went to
canada there's a very very big
disincentive to doing that
well i'd like to hear as a baseball fan
i'd like to hear from marty
because he really has done that team has
been glamorized and it's been it's a
great team and great players great
individual players
and let me know about the team a little
bit and how you're doing and
let's hear it come on that's a beautiful
thing to own
well we're not playing that great right
now
i really wanted to tell a little bit of
my story because i am
mexican-american both my parents were
mexican-american
i'm the oldest of 11 children
my father did not graduate from high
school he always
was very positive about i think his
platform was if you don't work
you don't eat i'm a vietnam vet
[Applause]
i was lucky enough when i came home to
get the gi bill and go to college
i went to the other school down in
tucson
[Applause]
i'm married to have three great children
my dad was very much a very goldwater
republican
[Applause]
we were brought up very conservative
just want to talk a little bit about
because i started my life as working for
someone and
started with a partner or small business
and over the years we grew it but
everybody deserves the opportunity to
grow your own business
it's a very important thing everyone
deserves a right to be able to raise and
educate their children a safe
environment
i have really been lucky to have the
opportunity to benefit from this
great american country
every person has an opportunity to have
a voice it's important that we it's
expressed
it's very important for every latino
american to get out
and vote it's our
it is our right to vote and express our
choice for president trump
and its leadership
we all know where we've been it's
necessary to focus on today and the
future
and it's very important to vote for
president trump
thank you for the opportunity well now i
really like that team i liked it before
i didn't know he was going to do that
but i tell you what i appreciate it and
you know your story is an amazing story
it's a great story think of that and
he's one of the most respected people in
sports and in business
and just a great story thank you very
much it's a great honor to be with you
thank you
thank you mr president uh and allow me
to join
with all these folks and welcoming you
back to arizona
it's
i'm sure i'm sure that this is a much
more hospitable
setting than what you were in california
just a little bit ago
but they were nice this is very special
exactly exactly um you know
my story is as uh 27 i was elected to
the state legislature
i represent a very fast growing area
between phoenix and tucson
uh that has been in the news quite a bit
with companies like nikola motors and
lucid motors
announcing their factories there
my family's been in the grocery business
since 1952.
they moved to arizona because they
failed at hog farming in iowa and i
think you have to actually try to do
that in iowa
but i opened up a business here in
arizona
my uh their first business went bankrupt
they pulled themselves up got back to
work opened a new grocery store
later on because you can do that in
arizona
you can do that in america to be able to
to be able to have failure and to come
back
and now my
here i am at age 27 in the state letter
or 35 excuse me
and uh living a wonderful life
and it's a it's something i think for a
lot of the folks out
right now to realize it is difficult to
be a minority
and republican at times because your
your friends
your other members of your family
oftentimes
uh don't understand treat you
differently things like that
and you experience things that you
probably shouldn't but
it is uh we are very proud people very
happy to be up here
um actually in a few weeks i'm going to
be getting married
melissa out there she's she's wearing uh
she's wearing it she's wearing a dress
by ivanka
she's wearing a dress by ivanka so you
can share that so
that's very nice but more than anything
uh
we 100 believe in what you're doing and
we want you to keep it up and we know
that the one way we can make sure that
it keeps up
is by getting out to vote and fully
supporting the trump
uh re-election campaign because that
will also help us in arizona
be able to keep the state senate and the
state house and we are very very close
and we want to have a huge turnout for
you and we appreciate you coming
we love that you're here and we hope to
see you many more times
and it is getting a lot easier to be
republican for as you say minority it's
getting a lot easier whether you're
hispanic or anything else
we're taking in people that are it's a
beautiful thing to see what's happening
with the republican
party and remember it's the party of
abraham lincoln a lot of people forget
that
abraham lincoln was a republican
the other side likes to try and claim
big disinformation but
they can't get away with that one so hey
thank you very much it's great
please go ahead
thank you mr president i
i'm here to share my american dream and
i want everyone
to know that our dream is still alive
the american dream is still alive and
i'm going to tell you a little bit of my
story
i came here to the united states when i
was 11 years old
my mom worked so hard to support all my
siblings
when i was 22 years old i got shot by
the father my kid
i survived horrible domestic violence
but after i got shot after a month of
getting better
i had two choices to make one was to
survive out of government welfare
survive out of government welfare or get
a job i chose to
get a job as a janitor
because for so much long i for the first
time i felt freedom
i felt that i needed to be free and i
didn't want to be dependent on the
government
so i started making five dollars an hour
in 1997
and i love my job so much that i work
my way up to become a supervisor manager
and then five years later
i end up buying my own uh my company my
own janitorial company
and for me that is looking at the
american dream
a high school dropout they didn't finish
high school i mean
what else can i do but to clean very
well and move up the ladder
that is the real american dream that's
what happens here
so from going to work eight hours a day
we end up working 16 hours a day for the
next
five years to pay off the big loans okay
then my fiance ron pickner now my
husband is here
help but i mean put together so after
after uh five years in 2005 we paid it
all off
then after that i started feeling that i
was getting more free and more free
and i'm i'm a giver i like to help
if god takes care of me i take care of
others
so what i do thank you
so i at that time in 2005 i had already
60 employees working for me
and one of the things that i love and do
for them is help them
learn english help them buy their first
car
help them get their first home but most
of the things that i enjoy
the most is teaching them english and
make them become u.s citizens
and over the course
over the course of i would say maybe 15
years
probably my husband and i helped more
than 30 people become u.s citizens
and i'm so proud of that it's incredible
then my american green was kept coming i
became a u.s citizen in 2008
then my america i kept leaving my
american dream and then
2012 came that's when obamacare came and
i
and they i keep hearing in the news if
you have more than 50 employees you have
to cut back
or you have to do something and i and i
told my husband what's going on
why am i have to lay off people and
that's when i started getting involved
more into what's going on why is the
government telling me what to do
i work so hard for what i have
why they have to get in my business why
do i have to let people go
thank you
so i started getting involved into local
politics and see
what they were doing why so they can
hear my american dream and see
i'm still here i'm still alive i want to
keep moving up
i don't like to sit and listen i'm the
one that wants to get active and
and do something about it there's a
problem so that's what i did
and look where he got me now i'm here
next to the president getting him up
thank you thank you
let's protect our country let's protect
our american dream
we're all we're all americans it doesn't
matter where you come from
this is our safe heaven please let's put
president trump again for the next four
years
thank you very much
[Music]
my name is gloria my name is gloria
badilla
and we are a small business owner we
live in tucson my husband and myself
and it is my honor to be sitting here at
the same table that you are
mr president trump thanks to you and the
policies
that you've been working with sba we
were able to save our small business
[Music]
as a mexican immigrant and u.s citizen
now to this beautiful country that i can
call my own
we have achieved our american dream we
make
fresh salsa and spices made out of
chiltepin peppers
[Applause]
we we feel so fortunate for the
opportunity to have this administration
be able to have our chiltepika products
flourish
even though we had the setback of the
pandemic we are doing
okay and we will survive this past
um we also wanted to thank you for
we have seen our neighbors our
communities uh even though like i said
for this pandemic
has not set everybody back it's been
hard for some people but we will
come out at the end good
also in tucson i've been very involved
with one of the
senators races that we have against
going to grijalva and it is my
mission and my husband to work with him
so we can get him through
and get grijalva's been in the senate in
the congress for
17 years so we too long yes
so we have congressmen not congressman
future congressman daniel wood and
that's what we're doing
products came out of nothing excellent
actually we had saved some money to
build a swimming pool in our home and we
thought you know
this could be something and my husband
and i thought
what we we do as the american dream as
our own business
and say well you make good salsa we'll
make good salsa
and that's how chiltepika products came
out of love
of cooking great that's great
thank you
mr president thank you my name is uh
jimmy chavez i'm the
chairman of the national troopers
coalition and i'm a 30-year law
enforcement veteran
i will tell you not only uh with the
group that i represent but as you
alluded to earlier in your opening
comments
your and your administration have shown
tremendous support for law enforcement
since day one
and that is something that we did not
see in the previous eight years before
you took office
so yes we thank you for that we thank
you for the support
we thank you for the dedication um
we know that you're uh your attorney
general uh william barr is doing a
tremendous job
uh we thank you for that
and it's it's exciting to be a part of
this panel because
i think including the the audience out
here i think that we can all agree that
safer communities pref provide
a benefit and provide
economic stability because if you don't
have a safe community
who's going to want to go out who's
going to want to go buy things
so this whole idea of defunding the
police or
cutting costs on law enforcement is
is something that is counterproductive
to what your administration wants
definitely and what we've seen over the
last three and a half years
four years with with the economic growth
in the country
there's no doubt that many agencies
across this country are seeing issues
with recruitment retention
equipment issues uh technology that is
that is
ever evolving and i think if we
if we have um ideologies
that continue to chip away and want to
erode
law enforcement i think that's going to
have a significant
effect on communities
significant effect on the citizens and
certainly a significant effect
on this country so as as a law
enforcement officer
again 30-year veteran and as one who
represents
law enforcement from country to country
or from coast to coast i'm sorry
we appreciate your support and
we will be there to offer the same
support back thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
and look what happened in new york where
they cut a billion dollars and they got
rid of a lot of uh
great great crime fighters and
look at what happened in a short period
of time austin pd
lapd uh texas dps is actually being
considered to take over uh austin pd
because of the drastic cuts that
occurred there so it's
it's having some ripple effects sounds
good good governor there
good governor thank you very much
appreciate it please
mr president i want to thank you very
much for this opportunity
it is an honor and a privilege to be
talking to you
to be part of this table my name is
jorge rivas
my wife and i rivas on
[Music]
we own a small business in tucson sami
is mexican grill
has to be doing well
how's it doing doing very good i want to
say that you're trying to
doing so well for a little while now
it's doing very good right
that's good your treats are really good
your treats have helped
tremendously thank you
before i came to the back room my wife
told me if i sit on the back make sure
you tell the president
that i respect him i love him so my wife
said that she respect you and she loves
you a lot
[Applause]
um since you announced that you will be
running for president
back in 2016 i told my wife
donald trump has what it takes to be the
next president of the united states
and we and we decided to support you
since
since the first first day um
back when you went to in 2016 when you
went to tucson and did a rally over
there
i decided to make a sign that says
latino support donald trump
because at that moment the media and a
lot of people were saying
latinos do not like donald trump but i
said that's not true
i said they are not going to keep me
quiet i'm going to keep talking
[Music]
um i love you too
um your wife
my wife understand jesus
she loved the president so we're we're
good
um so after having uh
people uh link our name our personal
names with our business we got a big
backlash you know people attacking us
but um we stay strong the last few years
i've been very involved you know not
only in the community but also
i'm a member of the what we call what we
think it is that
the most important or the biggest
republican club
in arizona which is the saddlebrook
republican club i know that we have some
members here
um and like i said
we've been very involved just yesterday
we my wife and i
organized a big uh car parade a trump
parade
on highway 77 or oprah road in tucson
a lot of people came over hundreds of
cars even some of
our friends a latino friend from nogales
drove almost two hours to come to the
parade
so there is a lot of support
for sure
many of them after i mentioned to them
that i was gonna i had the privilege to
come to meet with you
they said make sure you tell the
president not only that we respect him
we love them we'll be voting for him but
more than anything mr president
having a small business and talking to
hundreds and thousands of peoples a week
i know that a ton of people are praying
for you
are praying for yourself
thank you
thank you very much
thank you and i know that many of these
people are very
humble people so and i think that god is
listening to the prayers
so you are in good hands
my support for you is also
it more than anything is because you
show so much love for this country
i have i have learned
i have learned to appreciate respect
and love this country so much
because of the of the opportunities and
what gives
to everyone that comes here the
opportunity to live the american dream
one of the reasons that many of us
latinos like about you
is the straightforward way you're
talking that you have
youtube i i do not like when politicians
try to make you
hear or they try to tell you what they
think you want to hear
yeah just tell me the way it is it's
straightforward and that's why i think i
like you so much
many immigrants like myself or many
other people who their
fathers parents grandparents came here
100 200 years ago
we all came from here for for similar
reasons for security
for for safety for the opportunity
to own our own business and the
opportunity to raise our kids and our
families
in a safe stable environment
so that's why one of the reasons why we
support you and so many people support
you that people that i know they support
you as well
but the real reason is that i tweeted
out i saw they were giving them a hard
time
and i tweeted out this is a great couple
and i looked at him i said look at this
couple and they were giving him a hard
time
and they were trying to do a boycott
because this other side is very vicious
they'll try and do boycotts
so i said you know what it's not very
presidential but i'm going to do a tweet
for sammy and his beautiful wife
and
you never saw lines like this ever
before
and that's the reason and and i'll tell
you you have been
you've been great and i appreciate i
hear the place is doing fantastic so i'm
very welcome mr president thank you very
much
and i have a few more things um
my uh betty my wife and i were being
blessed with three
excellent young boys our boys three
young men
they're doing very well in college and i
feel that
every kid has the need to be supported
or to be loved since there are four five
six years old
help them in in high school helping them
get through college
we're like i said we've been blessed our
kids are graduating from from high
school from college
with honors and i i think that
part of the problem that we're having
nowadays in so many
people are looting so much hate breaking
windows
stealing somebody's property is because
the parents
are doing a poor job in helping the kids
[Applause]
in helping the kid the kids achieve
their dreams
their goals so if you are not there when
they are very young
do not expect them to be a very
good citizen when they get older yeah so
i feel that we as parents we need to do
a much better job
at raising our kids because if you're
not if you are
a a person of uh
either you're immigrant you are minority
you are hispanic or black
person if you are not helping your kids
when they're very young
do not come with me 10 years 15 years
later and tell me
that you have a sign for me to say to me
to
respect your sign that says black lives
matter you're
if you are being irresponsible not
helping your kids i will i will suggest
for you to
take your sign frame it and put it in
your house in your living room
and look at it every day and care for
your child
when they're young
[Applause]
[Music]
we need to keep the family structure
together
stronger family dad because for us
my wife and i work very hard in our
business 12 14 16 hours a day
but we we always make time to support
our children make sure that
you know that their needs were met you
know we are not rich or anything
like that we would make sure that they
had you know what they needed to succeed
and i think we are failing very
miserably on that
um when when your opponent is not saying
anything about all the destruction that
the people are doing out there
they're only promoting that destruction
so we
we as latinos we are people that that
care for our families
people that that that we call ourselves
christians
we must support someone in this case
president trump to lead this country for
another four years
thank you
[Music]
just two more sentences okay i'll be
done
[Laughter]
i feel uh mr president that we
if we call ourselves christians we
should
we should really think or maybe those
still people out there that comes
that consider themselves independent to
really think
what do you want your country to look
like in 10 years from now
do you want your kids to have an
opportunity to succeed
or do you want to have a breakdown in
society where they are not going to have
the options
to live the american dream so
for those reasons i feel that it's
extremely important
to listen to what the other side is
saying because for
the the the commercials that i see are
all based on lies
and hate let's let's let's lie about
what president trump is doing let's lie
about
you know blaming him for kobe 19 or
everything else
you know and they are not and they're
not showing any
structure or any goals or any plans of
what they're going to do
everything is based on attacking
president trump shame on you mr
biden
[Applause]
and lastly this last thing
as a as a good business owner as a
entrepreneur as an american
mr president i wrote a book i finished
writing a book two weeks ago
and i gave uh one of your white house
staff a book
to give it to you so if you please read
it i think it's very good
it is called it is called american
patriots
no no i'm sorry it doesn't well it is
called
modern patriots why modern because we
are
we feel that we as latino we are new
well like myself we're a new generation
but we all we're full of love for this
country and we're standing up for what
what is right
and we're standing up for you mr
president thank you
beautiful
thank you
that was a good job that was actually
very good are you proud of him
thank you go ahead
follow follow that go follow him go away
well thank you mr president for the
opportunity to speak with you today
my name is moses sanchez and i'm a legal
immigrant
from panama my family and i came to the
united states
during the reagan administration in
search of that american dream
and we've been pretty good with
doctorates nurses and
entrepreneurs in our family that are
contributing back
to the fabric of this country i've
proudly served
my navy's my country's navy combat team
for the last 24 years
with a tour in afghanistan in 2011.
now for decades our hispanic community
and persons of color
have been accustomed to getting lip
service from our political leaders
promises of better schools safe
communities
and economic security you delivered
on all your promises
that have improved the circumstances our
communities face
historical records in unemployment
home ownership massive investments into
opposite opportunity zones
and an economy that lifts all boats
my daughter shannon and i we own a
digital marketing company
named known as marketing it's her name
shannon
backwards good
when you came into office we had one
employee
at the beginning of this year we had
over 12 people in our office
working hard helping
other businesses increase and improve
their digital footprint
then covet hit and it impacted everyone
our company was no exception
we are fortunate to receive ppp funds
during the first round
many of our clients also received ppp
funds
the ppp loan helped us get through the
shutdown
and many of our clients were able to
stay afloat
now many are doing better not fully
recovered
but better go ahead kovid and these
shutdowns
have a huge impact on our economic
security
mental physical and spiritual well-being
my my
mr president my i think it's important
that
my my wife is an ob gyn here in phoenix
focusing on substance use disorders in
pregnancy
and parenting women she personally asked
me
to tell you that she really appreciates
all the work you've done in addressing
the often overlooked opioid crisis
we believe long-term shutdowns have
added to substance use
and we're glad that you're doing
everything you can to fight
covid and open our economies in a smart
safe and effective way and we're really
looking forward
to the continued recovery thank you mr
president thank you
thank you very much beautiful
say hello to your wife please that's
really nice i appreciate it
we have made a lot of strides with the
opioid and drugs but
you get set back with this this giant
virus was
a big setback but now we're back to uh
business
but we we did get set back with this
horrible thing that was sent it could
have been stopped it should have been
stopped
it should have been stopped they stopped
it going into their country
but not coming into our country not
coming into europe and the rest of the
world so
but i appreciate those are beautiful
words thank you very much please go
ahead
thank you thank you mr president welcome
back to arizona
my name is leah marcus peterson i serve
on the arizona corporation commission so
we regulate our public utilities among
other things
i'm also the past president of the
tucson hispanic chamber
and i've been a proud republican since i
was 18 years old
our family has a long history of small
business ownership
and that's really what resonated with me
as i was growing up in arizona
and it's really those values as
republican values of
less government more personal
responsibility that you've heard from
many of the other panelists today
i went on to own my own small businesses
a chain of gas stations and convenience
stores
as well as a business brokerage firm in
the tucson area also
i'm very proud though of leading our
tucson hispanic chamber which is one of
the largest hispanic chambers in the
nation with more than 1800 members and
during that time i worked with thousands
of small businesses
from pima county cochi santa cruz all
throughout southern arizona
and i wanted to mention to you just a
very big thank you for the tax and jobs
act
i saw first hand working with small
businesses in southern arizona
the impact on their businesses the
ability to acquire additional pieces of
equipment or hire new personnel
and it really had an impact secondly i
think the governor mentioned it also i
wanted to thank you for your leadership
on the usmca the u.s mexico canada
agreement that's great
thank you thank you as
as you're probably aware arizona does
more than 16 billion dollars in trade
with mexico they're our number one
trading partner
and you often hear about a lot of the
large companies and transactions but
there's so many small businesses
that are dependent on that relationship
so that really meant a lot to the
members of the chamber that i worked
with thank you
at the corporation commission i'm
working hard to ensure that businesses
and families are not going to be hit
by the radical california energy
policies that a lot of us are seeing now
we're hearing about the california
rolling blackouts we're trying to defend
our state against a lot of these
green new deal components that are
coming forward so
that's something that's very important i
know it's going to drive up energy
and i i know that you understand these
issues and
you've got our back there because we
need to do all we can to to
really recover from this economic time
and i think the cost of energy has a
a big part of what what's going to
impact families and businesses in the
future
but thank you president thank you very
please much you very much mr president
it's truly a privilege to be on this
panel and sitting at the same table with
you here today thank you for coming to
arizona
for the fifth time
my name is pam kirby and i'm a first
generation college graduate
i also serve on the latinos for trump
advisory board
and i'm the first vice chair of the
arizona republican party
most recently i completed eight years of
service on my local school board and in
the spirit of lifelong learning three
months ago i earned my master's in
education policy
i have a i have a lot of
responsibilities and priorities but my
passion lies with education policy and
that's what i'd like to talk with you
about today
um i first want to lead by thanking both
you and ivanka
who she did by the way she did a
fabulous job introducing you at the
convention
for the reauthorization i want to thank
you both for the reauthorization of the
perkins
career and technical education grant cte
grant that was worth over 30 million
dollars to arizona
for more than our 200 000 cte students
i wanna thank you for your efforts to
roll back
federal intrusion in our classrooms that
allows
that allows our local districts to
better respond to their communities
needs rather than
wasting valuable resources chasing down
one-size-fits-all mandates from
washington d.c
and you mentioned it earlier i'm
grateful for the opportunity zones that
you have created
because that encourages expansion of
quality charter schools in our most
underserved communities
mr president arizona is a national
leader in school choice but even so
80 of our 1.1 million k-12
students enroll in a public district
school
and almost half of them are latino
my eight years of service on the school
board taught me
that we cannot continue with the status
quo if we want to be competitive in a
global economy
we must stop the radical indoctrination
that's happening in our classrooms
[Applause]
we must stop the indoctrination and
instead teach our children to
love our country and all she has to
offer
and mr president that includes standing
for the american flag
[Applause]
we must have an education system that
prioritizes the children
over the adults and funds the student
instead of the institution
[Applause]
you know you talked about school choice
earlier there are a lot of candidates
out there who say
school choice for me but not for thee
we have to reject those candidates
because school choice cannot be reserved
for just the few people
we need to empower all parents with the
right
to choose the educational systems for
their children
and more importantly we need to empower
them with the means
to execute against that choice and when
we have done that
we will have truly freed all students
from their zip codes
so in closing mr president i want to
thank you for your commitment to the
american people and more importantly
i want to thank you for your commitment
to the most vulnerable of our society
our children
great job thank you school choice
absolutely right thank you please
mr president my name is sergio arellano
you can call me serge
[Music]
and i am a first generation american
my parents are from sonora mexico they
received their right to be here during
the ronald reagan amnesty
as a show of gratitude to the country
that allowed them to do that i enlisted
into the us
army on april 1 2001.
at the age of 17.
fast forward to september 11th which we
just recently
you did a great job in remembrance mr
president thank you
and i find myself deployed to ramadi
iraq september of 2003
and participated with the first in the
16th infantry division
on the fight for ramadi fallujah habaner
and al-assad
[Applause]
unfortunately after ten and a half years
in the infantry due to combat sustained
injuries i left the military as a
wounded warrior
and when i left the military i was lost
i was homeless i had a three-year-old
son
and now i have four
good job but it was really hard to
navigate the spectrum
to get services to get any help
whatsoever it's a travesty what the
government has done
to veterans when they get out of the
military
[Applause]
it's thanks to you and your laws and
your leadership
that allowed me to have choice when it
came to health care
not only for me but for thousands of
veterans in the state of arizona
[Applause]
i'm born and raised in tucson arizona
and i'm also a small business owner
entrepreneur and i'm also a school board
member
so donald trump's policies are music to
my ears
[Applause]
but i just wanted to bring a couple of
things from down south
from tucson and and bring it to the
table as to what the latino community is
feeling
and what it's missing and what it's
missing is more of your leadership
and latinos are conservative they just
don't know it
[Applause]
i'll i'll make it really quick i don't
want to drag on too long here
but ever since you were elected it's
been
easier and easier and easier to recruit
latinos
from all over the state
we started doing three-person trump
trains down in nogales
and we've grown i'm also on the advisory
board for latinos for trump
and we've grown our organization here to
include three victory offices for you
and also over 1100 volunteers for
latinos for trump
in the past three months
[Applause]
it is a critical time right now for our
kids for our family and for our children
and i'm going to give you just one
personal tale where
i had my kids in the car we pulled over
to the side of the street
we were playing pokemon go
and we got pulled over by a police
officer and
i told everybody you know relax these
are the good guys
police officer shows up says hey what's
going on are you okay
yeah my kids wanted to catch a pokemon
and he says well you can't be parked
here but you know go ahead
go on your road go go on your path
um this was about a year ago and my son
says dad
i haven't heard in my entire life and
he's 17 now anyone say
that a police officer is a good guy in
my neighborhood
this is the stuff we're facing in
southern arizona in tucson
in liberal ram areas that hate police
okay um so lastly
i want to really have my kids who are
your biggest fans
stand up and uh say hi to president
trump guys
they are your biggest biggest biggest
fans
in the world and they have your picture
in their house
and they're beautiful kids too thank you
so much president and in closing
when i tweeted that president trump was
coming to arizona for the fifth time
to hear latinos and their opinions
i had some hecklers say i'm sure
president trump will listen to you
here he is
thank you mr president thank you that's
a great job
that's a great job thank you very much
please good afternoon we welcome new
citizens who love
our people and share our values
poland speech 2017
immigrants enrich this country and i
want them to come in big numbers
the state of the union 2019.
mr president these words will resonate
with me
forever thank you so much for what you
do for the latino community
for securing our borders for supporting
legal
immigration and for your efforts again
child exploitation and
[Applause]
and for being so successful fighting
human trafficking
you heard us loud and clear and you know
that we want
safer communities my name is monica
yelling
i was born in bogota colombia i came to
this country in 1998
with a j-1 war visa just one piece of
luggage
and 300
in 2005 i proudly became a citizen of
this country
[Applause]
and right after my naturalization
ceremony in brooklyn new york
i drove as fast as i could to the new
york board of elections and i registered
to vote
live in port washington a little town
on the north shores of long island
my husband my husband is here and he's
a jewish american new yorker from new
rochelle
[Applause]
who is glowing full of excitement and
wanted me to thank you for
standing for israel
[Applause]
mr yelling never ever believe in any
candidate for presidency
until you run for presidency that's
right
so he voted for you that's great thank
you
that's really nice thank you very much
nice looking guy too
nice looking
[Applause]
and of course he owns a small e-commerce
and investments business
that even with this pandemic is still
succeeding
[Applause]
we left new york because of high taxes
the cost of living and as you know the
potholes
it's like too fun like this one
we came to arizona because it's a
prosperous state
today arizona is one of the fastest
growing
states we have surplus
and it is estimated that by 2022 57
billion
latinos will have that amount of in
power
in spending
[Applause]
thanks to your administration policies
latino families have more money
in their pockets because of the double
child credit
and the standard deduction the double
standard deduction furthermore
small and medium businesses are grateful
for your tax cuts and the deregulations
back in 2019 in september we had the
lowest latino unemployment rate
which was 3.9 percent and
in 2018 more than 362 000 latinos bought
homes around the country
thank you
years ago when i arrived alone
in this country i could have never
imagined the diverse and blessing
and blessings and the journey that i was
that was ahead of me
from getting a master's degree
translating everything at night at home
to becoming a chairwoman of a
large insurance industry committee in
the east coast
to director of strategic initiatives to
being elected by vote
to a county board to be appointed
as one of the members of commission of
domestic violence
to serving my community every day
and most important to be here today with
the president of united states of
[Applause]
america
i am a living proof of the american
dream
anything in this country is possible
and on behalf of many latinos around the
country
we want to thank you for leading this
nation
and fun and for sharing your family and
religious values with us
due to the nature of my uh duties
i communicate and i engage with
organizations and non-profits in the
community
every day and everyone
is aware that we are on the road to
recovery and
much faster than we expected
again thank you very much for
this wonderful opportunity and for
serving our country we love you
president trump
well i just want to finish by saying my
people told me this was going to take
about
one third of the time but after these
stories started going i wasn't leaving i
want to tell you they
they are they are incredible stories
success stories
all success stories uh you've done so
well
the hispanic community is amazing i knew
that immediately i knew that from many
years ago long before i thought about
doing this
whole deal in politics i didn't have to
be told about the hispanic community i
dealt with them
natural business people great business
people great great business people
you have to be very sharp when you deal
with hispanic americans
my latinos i love the latinos but but
i've always known how great you were i
mean artie's a great example of
one of your great examples of it but uh
it's a fantastic community i will never
let you down
i will tell you i'll never let you down
thank you thank you very much
thank you very much
let's go
[Music]
there's no need to feel down
young
[Music]
it's fun to stay
[Applause]
[Music]
you can do whatever
but you've got to know this
one thing no man does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
there
to the ymca
today
[Music]
you can hang out with all my boys
someone came up to me and said come here
take a walk up the street it's a place
there
call the ymca they can't stop
[Music]
there's no need